wenn wir über eine impfpflicht reden
genau wie sie es gesagt haben frau
wagenknecht dass wir im grunde über
jahren im abo reden über eine
impfpflicht ich weiß nicht ob sie sich
herr stegner und herb lausanne den
werbespot der bundesregierung vom
gesundheitsministerium und robert
koch-institut erinnern mitteilt
carpendale der mal anfängt mit dem hello
again so könnte der in zukunft aussehen
wir sind dann mal ran gegangen von bild
ich komme würden weiterhin
kommen sie zur schutzimpfung
hello again
ich komme hier wegen meine vierte
impfung
ach kommen sie zur fünften
auffrischungsimpfung
halogen ich komme hier wegen meine
sechste impfung
halogen ach kommen sie zur siebten
auffrischungsimpfungen der
kabine
ja herr stegner herr plus ist das ein
hauptgrund weswegen das so schwierig ist
wie haben das jetzt einmal der typ
bewusst überzeichnet aber ist das ein
hauptpunkt herr stegner warum das so
schwierig ist mit der impfpflicht dass
wir gar nicht sagen können wie wirksam
sind erst zwei impfungen wie viele
impfungen braucht es tatsächlich das
glaube ich glücklich überhaupt nicht und
ich finde das ja sehr lustig aber im
kern reden wir natürlich weder über
lustige noch immer abstrakter
akademische frage auch niemand von uns
hier es wissenschaftler das weiß ich
kann nur sagen dass schutz der
bevölkerung ist offenbar erheblich
größer wenn die menschen bewusst sind
dass dies so und ich würde man etwas
erinnern was uns aus dem gedächtnis geht
allmählich wie viele menschen sind vor
dem vorletzten jahren im letzten jahr
gestorben da sind welche gestorben weil
es den impfstoff noch nicht gab jetzt
sterben menschen auch deswegen weil
übertragung stattfinden weil manche die
sich impfen lassen könnten ist nicht tun
und zwar viel weniger und auch wenn der
pigs regelmäßig sein sollte was ich
nicht weiß ich bin kein wissenschaftler
verglichen mit dem was die alternative
dazu möglicherweise ist und ich sage
nochmal wir hatten in der geschichte
unserer republik weder dieses maß an
freiheitsbeschränkung die wir alle in
nehmen mussten solche dinge gab 70 jahre
überhaupt nicht
doch das ausmaß an leiden und sterben
durch eine infektion in diesem maße das
will ich noch mal ausdrücklich sagen und
es finden demonstrationen in deutschland
statt und nicht nur meinungsfreiheit
ausgeübt wird sondern vor fehlten uns
verbreitet werden wo behauptet wird es
eben sei gefährlicher als die krankheit
selbst wo leute aufgehetzt werden sich
nicht ändern zu lassen das stimmt teuer
so was gerade sehr trägt dazu bei
menschen zu gefährden und da ist der
punkt wo ich gern noch mal auf die bank
eingehen möchte ich glaube es ist ganz
wichtig zu sagen dass wir die
bürgerlichen freiheitsrechte schützen
aber die freiheitsrechte haben auch dort
ihren begrenzung wo sie anderen
gesundheit unternehmen gefährden und das
ist der punkt über den wir hier sehr
ernsthaft miteinander ringen ob das das
richtige mittel ist weiß ich nicht aber
im augenblick sagen alles ist vermutlich
der beste weg oder eine große mehrheit
sagt dass die umfragen sagen dass auch
die menschen sind ja nicht nur und
darüber redet liegen war es dann darum
ringen heute im schloss auch darüber
redet heute berg ja auch in der eigenen
partei extrem hart auch innerhalb der
ampel koalition wird extrem hart
gerungen haben sie den überblick vor
teuteberg ob sie innerhalb der eigenen
fraktion mit ihrem nein zur impfpflicht
mehrheit haben oder ob es ein klares
jahr zur impfpflicht in der fraktion
gibt wie sie ihr eindruck bisher
auch ich habe respekt vor jedem und
jeder kollegin die sich diese
entscheidung nicht leicht machen und
damit sich bringen ich habe keinen
aktuellen genauen überblick wie viele
abgeordnete gerade sind und aus welchen
fraktionen es sind schon aus
verschiedenen fraktionen abgeordnete
dabei aber wichtig ist doch wie wir an
die sache rangehen zum einen ist mir
ganz klar dass der fonds gern davon
ablenken will dass die union sich selbst
nicht einig ist wie sie an die dinge
herangehen will und deshalb auch gerne
auf das thema impfpflicht übrigens
ablenkt werden gerade eine mdk und da
gibt's die einen da bringt hausherr hans
oder herbst den alles nicht genug ist
die am besten die epidemische notlage
wieder ausrufen lassen wollen und dann
gibt es die anderen in bayern oder in
sachsen anhalt sie einfach mal
ankündigen sie würden zweig plus nicht
ohne weiteres umsetzen das ist völlig
widersprüchlich und zeigt dass hier
viele doch ersatz diskussionen führen
ich mache mir große sorgen um
gesellschaftliche verwerfungen
vertrauensverlust frage wie auch gleich
in meiner frage ganz das aus gekommen
das ist auch schon wichtig heute bei
verzeihen sie ist ja schon wichtig auch
ob sie wie viel rückendeckung sie für
ihren antrag auch in den eigenen reihen
im zweifel haben ob die wie die fdp dazu
stimmen von ihrem parteichef zum
beispiel wissen es gar nicht wie er dazu
steht aktuell vom bundesfinanzminister
wir haben hier das gruppen verfahren und
den die freie entscheidung im bundestag
unabhängig von fraktionsgrenzen wir
haben in sein angebot gemacht den kann
sich abgeordnete anschließen und dann
werden wir eine sorgfältige
orientierungs debatte führen wie sich
das für ein so ernstes thema gehört und
das ist mir eben auch sehr wichtig denn
ich habe den eindruck dass einige mit
besonders harten und schnellen
ankündigungen manchmal wettmachen wollen
dass die lage so schwierig ist und so
war das auch vor weihnachten dass er
manchmal schnell handlungsfähigkeit
suggeriert wird durch ankündigungen
statt sich auf das zu konzentrieren was
notwendig ist zum beispiel
bezieht das auf die ganze familie und
verschiedenste dinge dass man ja doch
einige nur angekündigt eine ganz
lautstark haben sie da den kanzler
gemeint liegt ja nahe
ich wünsche mir von allen
verantwortlichen dass sie jetzt nicht
gesetzliche pflichten die wenn überhaupt
erst im nächsten herbst eine praktische
rolle spielen würden selbst wenn man sie
beschließen würde sondern dass wir jetzt
auf die schnelle und seriöse
datengrundlage setzen da hat ja auch
herr söder einiges aufzuarbeiten
in seinem bundesland dass wir die
verfügbarkeit der enz für sicherstellen
da hatte er der
bundesgesundheitsminister auch vor
weihnachten sorgen geäußert ob das jetzt
im januar klappt damit alle menschen die
sich jetzt impfen lassen wollen auch
impfstoff verfügbar bekommen und einen
termin bekommen das sind wichtige dinge
und dass wir ehrlich sind darin ist es
wichtig dass das politik gerade in so
einer dauer herausforderung ehrlich ist
darin was sie weiß und was sie nicht
weiß und sich auf das konzentriert was
sie aufgrund des vorhandenen wissens
auch verantwortlich entscheiden kann und
wir wissen jetzt dass das vor schweren
verläufen schützt die impfung deshalb
ist es gut wenn sich viele menschen
impfen lassen aber wir müssen genauso
ehrlich sein zu sagen dass wir weiter
tests und vorsicht brauchen dass die
impfung allein das nicht überflüssig
macht und dieser eindruck wird aber
erweckt um die impfpflicht
verhältnismäßiger erscheinen zu lassen
und genau deshalb braucht es auch die
andere position und die engagierte
argumentation dazu